vous avez tous été profondément ému par
la mort de jérémy cohen ce jeune homme
lâché par plusieurs individus avant
d'être percuté par un tram à bobigny
c'est une affaire qui agite depuis hier
la classe politique à cinq jours du
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle il ya soit le témoignage
de son père sur notre plateau a été
largement relayée par les médias et sur
les réseaux sociaux que jérémy était
très doux quand il était gentil et j'ai
moins tant que père je voulu être là
pour le protéger j'ai pas pu et si cette
histoire est aujourd'hui révélées au
grand jour et qu'une enquête a été
ouverte c'est par le biais d'un candidat
il a fallu que ce le père de ce jeune
homme écrit pour que je le porte sur
dans les bains publics aujourd'hui
depuis fabien roussel jean luc mélenchon
ou encore marine le pen ont pris la
parole le sujet est évidemment
bouleversé tout le monde il faut que la
lumière soit faite via l'elysée a même
tenu à contacter la famille certains
dénoncent alors une récupération
politique à cinq jours du premier tour
de l'élection présidentielle alors à
faire jérémy cohen pensez vous que les
politiques soient sincères dans leur
combat
alors je voudrais dire un petit truc
déjà c'est que moi j'ai appris la faire
il ya une semaine déjà je vous dis
comment j'ai appris la faire c'est que
mon papa travail à bobigny et donc il a
vu les flyers circuler et il m'en a
parlé on a commencé à enquêter avec avec
nos équipes sur cette affaire et c'est
pour ça c'était bien avant ce week end
qu'on avait déjà vous voulez déjà
contacté la famille de jérémy mais voilà
je n'ai pas du tout appris par le biais
des médias vraiment eu enfin je suis
au hasard des circonstances mon père
travaille vraiment à bobigny et d'abus
passé ce flyer et cet appel à témoin
à la demande du chef de l'état le
capitaine emmanuel macron a appelé hier
la mère puis le père de jérémie cohen le
cabinet du président a téléphoné pour
leur transmettre un message de
compassion et leur faire savoir que dans
le respect de l'indépendance de la
justice tous les moyens d' enquêtes
seront mises en oeuvre pour identifier
les auteurs de cette agression et faire
toute la lumière sur cette affaire
j'aimerais qu'on se pose les vraies
questions et que vous répondiez
sincèrement toutes les questions que
l'on se pose qu'il ya plein de gens qui
disent vous allez voir voilà c'est ça
traîne parce que c'est les élections
aussi que en ce moment voilà il voit là
il faut on laisse couler son verra ça
après les élections voilà qu'est ce que
vous en pensez alors ça c'est pas la
même question moi je pensais à la
sincérité des politiques mais là je vous
rejoins tout à fait c'est pas hasard et
on le verra dans les déclarations du
procureur et moi ça me révolte j'ai une
colère froide c'est pas hasard si on ne
veut pas reconnaître que c'est un acte
antisémite alors si rld est ce qu a dit
le procureur actes eux mans qui s'est
exprimé au sujet de la sphère laissions
il est revenu sur les premières
investigations et a déclaré qu'il n'y
avait pas encore de motifs roger sémites
d'après lankais oui voilà regarde il ne
ressort pas des témoignages recueillis
jusqu'à présent
que l'agression était été commises pour
des motifs discriminatoires
aucun élément ne permet à ce jour
d'établir avec certitude que la victime
était porteuse de manière apparente ou
non d'une kippa au moment de la scène de
violence
bien évidemment tout élément permettant
d'établir un motif discriminatoire à
cette scène de violence en particulier
antisémite
donnera lieu à une aggravation de la
qualification pénale retenue
à l'origine alors on a déjà connu ça
avant d'autres élections moi je vous le
dis avec toute ma sincérité ça n'engage
que moi je suis persuadé que n'ayant pas
forcément de reçu de consignes mais la
justice traîne la justice ne veut pas
reconnaître que ça peut être antisémite
pour avoir assez volcanique ça entraîne
à une éruption sociale une éruption
politique juste avant les élections
c'est trop sulfureux
je réponds à votre question est ce qu'on
nous cache des choses oui oui on nous
cache des choses et on ne veut pas
reconnaître que c'est antisémites alors
que saleh guillaume gille tu veux pas
juger une affaire c'est un langage avec
ma sincérité langage économique le
discours du procureur c'est le discours
de l'avocat hier qu'ils condamnaient
fermement le évidemment le caractère
antisémite éventuelle de ce crime et là
il ya apparemment rien qui peut
déterminer ça pour l'instant moi ce qui
m'étonne c'est que sur la vidéo qui est
atroce il ya beaucoup de gens dans la
vidéo il ya des témoins ya quelqu'un qui
filme aussi m'étonne c'est que personne
ne soit en mesure de dire voilà les
insultes qui auraient été éventuellement
conduire l'enquète avançant avant cela
en tout cas on ne peut pas juger une
affaire en disant je pense que il me
semble que
mon avis mais moi j'ai ouvert ce qui
accroît dans cette histoire et raymond
on en a parlé hier c'est ce que tu étais
venu me voir dans ma loge ir et tu m'as
dit un truc qui m'a dit c'est vrai que
si avait pas eu les les enfants de
monsieur cohen l'histoire et hier on
exactement il n'y a pas la détermination
si les enfants décident pas de monde de
faire le leur propre enquête si tu
tombes sur une famille qui est qui est
meurtri on se doute qu'ils doivent êtres
meurtris je rentre chez toi la police se
dit c'est un accident dû aux caisses un
accident il est mort on enterre on passe
à autre chose et c'est un accident et on
sait pas on va pas plus loin si tu
tombes sur des gens qui ceux qui
pleurent leur chagrin et ou même qui est
fils unique il n'a pas de frère et tu
tombes sur des parents et ils ont perdu
leur seul fils ils vont croire à la
version qu'on leur a donné c'est un
accident pour répondre avec samassa
masse ça m'a gêné ce truc là maintenant
tant mieux qu'ils se soient battus faut
que l'anc est à l'avance et sur la
sincérité des politiques pendant que j'y
suis moi j'y crois pas une seconde c'est
que eux ils réagissent que uniquement
quand c'est médiatisé d'aix a explosé
dès que ça fait un an que ce mémoire il
pouvait passer ici il ya plein
d'histoires toute l'année de la violence
à lille at on tant la violence ça n'est
pas que maintenant l'alliance elle est
là toute l'année tous les jours dans
tous les journaux tu vois de la petite
violence ils s'en emparent jamais il en
aurait un accès pas toujours des bugs
elle commença à temps benjamin avec ça
commence à renifler que la merde elle
commence à monter ah bah oui alors on va
faire d'une affaire ceci et je finirai
par un truc moi j'en ai marre de cette
justice aussi c'est si un truc qui me
sens bizarre dans la justice ça va être
plus grave si c'est à caractère
antisémite cissé à caractère musulman si
c'est un caractère catholique
normalement un mec est mort un mec est
mort il n'y a pas que ce soit plus grave
il faut retrouver les mecs qu'on fait ça
il faut les condamner et qui prennent
cher pour envoyer encore une fois de
plus je le dis tout le temps le message
qu'on peut pas pour chasser des gens
tapaient des mains plusieurs il est jeté
sous un train c'est pas possible alors
le truc de caractère antisémite
caractère musulman
c'est les valeurs du main oui enfin
c'est de voir quand même extrêmement
grave au change et ça ça allait changer
à
jamais vraiment s'il est sûrs et si tu
as tu de ta croyant genci tutukin 4 le
convaincant il reprendre 15 bateaux et
le cas parce que tel salut ma soeur et
moi je voulais revenir sur ce qu'a dit
raymond à propos de l'accident c'est
pour ça que je maintiens ce que je
disais au début on part d'un accident de
tramway dramatique comment voulez vous
que la justice reconnaisse en quelques
semaines que cet accident de tramway
était potentiellement un acte antisémite
c'est pas possible tu as eu à dire que
je deviens toi mais que la justice
reconnaisse paris elle a juste ne pas le
reconnaître c'est pour ça que je suis
persuadé qu'on nous cache des choses ça
va j'espère que la vérité sortira jamais
être très près sur cette affaire-là j'ai
un gros doute que les pouvoirs publics
la justice ait envie vraiment sa belle
traité renonce à sa tête un bordel
lorsqu'il y aura plein de mecs qui est
ce qu'on a pu entendre le ce que c'est
un climat tendu c'est le conducteur
aussi du tram alors il est extrêmement
choqué qu'un examen pour homicide sur un
truc du lait dévasté il est extrêmement
chaud sur sa même ça vous rendez compte
lewarde et rend compte que lui même ici
d'un volet des recettes mais qu'on la
con il conduisait un rat - à 20 heures
mais qui travaille pour 1500 1600 bal
des cymbales peu importe il est dans son
tramway il ya malheureusement mémoire et
compte le drame tragique le drame boulot
mais on lui dit toi aussi tu vas venir
et tu vas être convoqué pour homicide au
jard est un tramway comme si j'arrête à
une trottinette c'est un tramway vont
lui il a déboulé devant moi les mecs
vous êtes tard et les gars c'est quoi
c'est non mais on marche sur la tête non
mais là le mec il est convoqué à la
barre alors on va voir juste un hic
c'est que vous avez vu que depuis le
début eric zemmour parle beaucoup de
cette affaire est en fait gérald cohen
le père de jérémy a expliqué hier sur le
plateau de bfm qu'il avait lui-même
demandé aux candidats d'intervenir
regardez moi j'ai demandé l'aide à ceux
qui pouvaient m'aider donc je voulais
j'ai demandé effectivement eric zemmour
s'ils pouvaient nous aider dans le cadre
de l' enquête pour faire quelque chose
et il a essayé de nous aider dans une
période à un moment donné je lui avais
demandé jeu demandée pour voir si on
peut faire quelque chose pour notre fils
et et pour pas que l'en tête
soit fermée ou étouffés et il a bien
voulu faire de ça je l'en remercie pas
alors c'est bon ça aussi qu'on parle de
récupération politique là même le chef
de l'état un qui a réagi vous verrez sa
réaction tout à l'heure mathieu
appris en regardant chez vous et ce qui
me choque effectivement comme comme
réponse est que un pardon mais des
acteurs jeremy cogne en a tous les bien
sûr tous les jours pendant cinq ans
zafar colonna les gens qui sont battus
dans les prisons des fissures sont
violés tout ça c'est tous les jours tous
les jours tous les jours et la larme à
l'oeil tout d'un coup une semaine avant
les élections l'impression que tous ces
gens découvrent découvre ce qui se passe
oui ça me choque alors je sais pas si
ils ont retrouvé une qui part par terre
je suis pas sûr que les mecs en lui
courant derrière pour lui piquer un truc
c'est comme quand tu coures derrière
quelqu'un pour voler est ce que tu sais
si les gués pagaie j'en sais rien je
sais pas si steve antisémite ou pas tout
ce que je sais c'est que des pauvres
mômes comme ça qu'ils sont qui se font
agresser par 15 personnes est qui et qui
meurt à son âge y en a tous les jours et
comme par hasard où on les voit tous
palerme à l'oeil zemmour le premier même
pardon un maquereau tout ça tout d'un
coup prend le sujet très au sérieux une
semaine avant tu dirais je non mais je
vois là bas coûts inférieurs ce qui me
pénard buy essays oui c'est ça me choque
parce qu'ils prennent c'est une semaine
avant et quand il ya des élections sera
pas seront passées on ne l'aura plus
rien à [ __ ] de moi alors je vous
dirais que j'ai vu le pape à dire et
minières non après l'émission ma faute
je vous le dis on a eu pas mal évolué
énormément de mal dans mes cheveux dit
mathieu g t au non je te raconte pas ce
qu'ils étaient là hier son papa il y est
resté de longues minutes ici sur le
plateau et je vous jure son père il est
fissurée en fait hier sa vie c'est fini
c'est terminé elle a séduit il est plus
là mais on les dit que smart y avait
quoi la halle c'est vrai et c'est vrai
qu'on a eu énormément de peine 1 et crée
mon bras mais on était resté en pensant
à la presse et c'est vrai que c'était
une image vraiment mais après très très
difficile de voir son papa et on peut
pas oublier ça on peut pas après passer
à autre chose et c c c c il sait même
pas ce qui lui arrive il comprend pas
c'est oui oui mais non mais mathieu
évidemment sur l'opportunisme et le
cynisme des hommes politiques à moins
d'une semaine de du premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle mais malgré
tout moi j'ai trouvé tellement
incroyable le papa de jérémy cohen hier
de courage de pugnacité en fait ça lui
dépasse complètement mais en fait on
s'en fout qu'il soit prose le problème
c'est pas si les pro zemmour pro mac
rompre au tel ou un tel il est juste
prompt faire la lumière sur cette
affaire immonde d'accord l'armée et donc
mais je suis d'accord mais sur ce qu'ils
font en pleine élection eh bah sinon
mais bien sûr que si bien sûr que si je
pense que là vraiment je pense que tu
fait fausse route parce que même si on
n'était pas en pleine élection il aurait
demandé à zemmour il aurait demandé à
mâcon et je pense malgré tout youri
quand même ainsi la bottine amour et
respect le premier c'est ce qui leur est
parlant je te coupe la télé là il a eu
la chance de venir dans cette émission
et du coup on en parle et cyril l'a reçu
et on est proche des élections sinon la
suite s'arrêter quoi tu sais que c'est
la suite pour ces gens là c'est du pénal
ces cinq six sept ans pour que pour
qu'il y ait un pur mais qui sait
pourquoi ils ont par là et c'est ce
monsieur dévastèrent attendu sept ans
peut-être pour un point c'est ridicule
et peut-être un non lieu parce qu'on
n'aura pas trouvé les personnes pour qui
c'est pourquoi il en parle parce qu'à
chaque fois qu'il ya des faits divers il
ya mais le papy voise sais pas si tu te
souviens en 2002 et savait jouer sur
justement jospin éjecté et le pen au
deuxième tour donc forcément les uns
politique et sont obligés de s'emparer
de ce truc là parce qu'à l'époque
personne n'avait parlé aux personnes
s'étaient émus et on avait dit justement
que les faits divers faisait l'élection
présidentielle donc là ils sont tous
obligés et j'espère peut-être par
cynisme mais si ça peut servir ne serait
ce qu'une personne qui a vu quelque
chose qui a entendu quelque chose ben
moi je dis ton mieux en fait 30 jusqu'à
tu trouves ça normal de la récupération
politique à ce moment là moi je suis
désolé un jeu je déshumanise pas du tout
les hommes politiques c'est pas parce
que tu es un homme politique que tu n'es
pas papa que tu n'es pas touchés par
cette histoire terrible maintenant si tu
est touché tu appelles la famille je
présente mes condoléances tu dis que tu
vas te bouger mais tu commences pas au
jt de tf1 en disant que c'est la
première chose que tu vas faire devant
des millions de personnes parce qu'à un
moment donné il faut respecter la
famille et que là c'est de la pure il de
l'eau de la famille
jt tf1 tu le fais chez toi tu vas a
plaidé jean tu veux donc besoin la
médiatisation ils sont là aussi il a
besoin d'aller le dire au jt tf1 comme
sa première mesure man men 1 de son
aimée encore été trente ans et qu'il
dise ça ne doit plus jamais arriver chez
d'accord ça arrive tout le temps je suis
d'accord c'est quand tu d'accord doit
plus arriver mais celui-là voilà gilles
verdez je suis pas d'accord avec mathieu
et franck sait sur quoi et je crois
qu'ils sous-estiment quelque chose
d'incroyable
si ce jeune homme a été tué parce qu'il
est juif c'est un une affaire d'état
dont on va entendre parler pendant 10
ans et ça et ça c'est pas du cynisme les
politiques qui ont vu l'évolution de la
sphère qui voit très bien que c'est
potentiellement un drame abominable
abominable ils sont obligés de monter au
créneau contre la société monte au
créneau pas le boulet soit juste finir
le bruit que ça fait aujourd'hui c'est
non seulement parce que ce jeune homme
est extraordinaire que sa famille est
incroyable mais parce que si jamais il a
été tué parce qu'il est juif là on est
dans quelque chose dont on peut voir
entendre parler pendant 10 ans camille
donc tercea c'est un drame que vous
sous-estimez je trouve ça du tout
d'habitants mais mme jarallah mais j'ai
changé de récupération il ne savait pas
ce que c'est cette argile et n'aurait
pas été juste si tu te rends pas compte
mathieu tu te rends pas que nos flancs
tisser long si j'ai eu c'est un gilet on
agit renard il c'est le racisme chez
sage et c'est des belles phrases mais
grave que tu es non c'est pas des masses
c'est bien ce que tu dis il sait très
bien tu le ressens tu en train de me
vendre un truc fait mais moi je suis moi
je suis plus dans le monde de oui oui ça
fait longtemps jeu là oui ça va être
extraordinaire les voir les mesures et
ça va être fort moi tu sais ce qui
résonne dans ma tête avec ces histoires
là ilan halimi c'est ça qui résonne dans
ma blessure et tu me dis disons vont
entendre parler que l'on dise en
caisse qui a bougé y'a rien n'a bougé
rien n'a bougé on est dedans on est
toujours dans des dans des attaques on
est toujours dans tout ce soit un jour
les musulmans ou s'aimer catholique où
se on est toujours dans des attaques
comme ça donc tu as beau me dire ici les
politiques qui vont s'en occuper il
s'occupe d'eux que dalle ilan halimi les
parties lui les parties yahia de notre
audience sarramagna les parties essayant
ne bouge pas c'est toujours pareil on
n'est pas aidés dommage parce que
réalisera ce que tu as me joue le direct
mais il aimerait ramener un chapeau sur
la tête c'est tout c'est exact mais non
tu meurs tu meurs pas parce que tu as
mis un chapeau sur la tête de l'anc est
elle va avancer moi je suis pas
procureur je suis pas juge je sais pas
pourquoi il ya eu cette histoire là mais
j'espère que c'est pas ça parce que
sinon ça comme tu as dit on va en
entendre parler pendant 18 ans dix ans y
aura un autre il y aura un autre jérémy
dans le parisien
majorité mais c'est ça la véritable info
pro c'est ça la vérité a thief contre
savourant des mégacités séparément des
pages il s'épanouit
jbg vocalises j ai qu est ce qui vous
dérange dans ce qu'ils disent que pour
l'instant l'histoire se répète
l'histoire voilà et et en quoi ils ont
tort en fait
jamais dit que j'arrêtais zemmour les
extrêmes et je ne dis pas ça mais y
avait une phrase qu'il avait dit que
j'avais noté il avait juste dit on en a
marre d'allumer des bougies c'est vrai
est systématiquement pour aller il ya un
moment où il faut faire des choses voilà
c'est ça et pas que pour les actes
antisémites faut faire des choses pour
les mecs qui se font agresser que
pourrait bien venir la main qui me
regardent du nord parce qu'il n'a pas
voulu donner de cigarettes mais c'est
quoi cette société y a pas que pour les
actes comme ça c'est tout
pareil morts c'était aujourd'hui les
mêmes à bouleverser faire
unités bouleversé que ce soit pas faire
vraiment où mathieu devant son poste et
et vous chers téléspectateurs par voilà
ce que vous avez pu lire moi j'ai dit un
truc voilà je le redis vraiment il faut
vraiment
que vous soyez fiers de votre religion
quelle qu'elle soit je le dis je le
redis c'est vrai que moi je vous le
redis voilà les catholiques doivent être
fiers de leur religion mais juifs les
musulmans c'est vrai que c'est
aujourd'hui aussi il ya des musulmans
qui se cache voilà il ya des catholiques
qui vont te dire je vais à la messe tous
les trucs parce que ya des juifs qui
veulent paquet au turf permetter qui je
vous le dis aujourd'hui ça c'est
insupportable
moi je rêve d'une france la voilà
qui vraiment qu'il soit fier de sa
religion et qu'ils soient fiers d'alliés
dans des lieux de culte voilà je vous le
dis soit fier d'aller à la mosquée à la
synagogue à l'église c'est ça que je
veux et c'est vrai que hier quand j'ai
montré tout ce qui s'est passé à new
york un avec cette grande prière pour le
ramadan ça c'était incroyable c est ça a
été une image qui a été reprise partout
une image de paix incroyable et je le
dis le 25 décembre on aimerait avoir une
messe voilà dans tous les voilà au
trocadéro voilà je vous dis pour anouk
aller mieux allumer les bougies et puis
je vous dis c'est magnifique et les gens
aiment ça au contraire ça fait partie
malade at il dit on apprend une culture
est serré c'est vrai que c'est
insupportable de voir de plus en plus de
gens qui ont honte d'être religieux de
croire en dieu et de respecter leur
religion et 2 pratiquer leur religion
voilà ça c'est devenu insupportable vous
avez raison cyril a atteint un niveau
près on a tous notre religion et aucune
n'est meilleure qu'une autre à un point
après c'est que justement le fait d'être
dans un pays laïc faits anciens qu'on
peut tous vivre ensemble et que
justement riz et que je joue très mal et
va se balader et qu'on puisse tout sept
frères et tout ça et on peut tu perds ta
petite chaîne ma chaîne a aucun souci
mais effectivement là où c'est important
de respecter la laïcité c'est ce qui
fera en sorte même si ça vous a dérangé
7 mai à 7,7 ce rassemblement il te
déranger je sais plus a dit que c'était
dérangeant dans un pays où il y avait en
septembre je suis plus qu'à lycée autour
de la table hier
gemalto non au contraire c'est très beau